[Music]
thank you
they gave us injections I didn't even
know I was pregnant the injection they
gave me I lost the pregnancy
they told us they would give us an
injection but they didn't tell us what
it was but they said it was even better
it's aborted because it's a book of
Haram child
[Music]
when I came out of the Bush it's when
they brought us back to their military
camp
I saw the rushes all over our bodies we
were sick they came and told me they
would give me an injection
they gave me an injection and when they
did that I lost the pregnancy
I was ill and I was bleeding so much
women who have been rescued and the rest
of them they're all gathered together
and brought some are found pregnant
they're separated from those who have
given birth already
they're put to the side they take the
pregnant ones because they don't want
them to give birth to children who will
grow up with the blood of Boko Haram in
their bodies that's the reason why they
give them abortions
[Music]
it's done in secret unless you go inside
the place you wouldn't know what's
happening in there
it doesn't ever happen it is not
happening and it will not happen it is
not in our character
we are handy professional we are human
beings and these are Nigerians they have
been talking about
[Music]